we have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine to David P. here is a question about
Andrew Yang.
It could actually apply to many of the candidates
running on the democratic side right now,
but it's about Andrew Yang.
So we will answer it as such.
It is, I'm a big fan of the show.
Um, my question is, will you think about,
um, Andrew Yang, um, being in 5% and the,
in a few polls recently, here's a 5% in Nevada
and 5% in Arizona.
Do you think this is showing like he's getting
up to that 5% threshold or do you think they're
both outliers or do you think that they shouldn't
be counted for some other reason?
Thanks.
Yeah, so listen, it's not about those poles
being outliers.
It's not about, they shouldn't be counted.
It's just not going to make a difference.
Okay?
Now, because this analysis could be done for
a bunch of the lower level candidates, I'm
going to do it for Andrew Yang, who I like
personally, and I've interviewed multiple
times because the caller asked about Andrew
Yang nationally.
Andrew Yang is polling at 2.8% okay?
But the primary is 50 individual state elections
plus some territories.
So the caller mentions in Nevada, that's the
third state to vote.
It goes Iowa, New Hampshire, then Nevada.
Uh, it's true that you, Andrew Yang voted,
uh, pulled 5% in one of the four recent polls.
Now, in the other three or four recent polls,
he's only pulling 3%, but it doesn't matter
because there's something called the 15% threshold
to receive any delegates.
Even if Andrew Yang in Nevada gets 14% of
the vote, assuming that there are other candidates
who get 15% or more of the vote, Andrew Yang
doesn't get any delegates, right?
He gets zero delegates.
So his 5% in Nevada or his 3% aren't going
to get them any delegates.
That's just the way it works, right?
It's not my opinion.
That's just the way it works.
Then you go to Arizona.
It's true.
There is a poll out of Arizona.
We're Andrew Yang has 5% now Arizona doesn't
vote until March 17th and there's a whole
bunch of States that will have already voted,
but again, ignoring that there's a 15% threshold
that has to be met.
If Yan gets his 5% of the vote in Arizona
in almost every circumstance he gets zero
delegates, so I'm not trying to bust anyone's
bubbles.
I'm just wondering if some people don't know
the primary process and how that threshold
works because once you recognize that three
or 5% it doesn't actually make a difference
in helping him to secure the democratic primary
nomination nomination.
Now, if you understand that, but you still
believe that there's a path, then I want to
hear from you.
I want to hear what that path is.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about McDonald's firing their
CEO for a relationship he had with an employee.
We will talk about Apple pledging billions
of dollars to fight the California housing
crisis and much more.
Get instant access to the bonus show instant.
It's under a minute.
By signing up@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidpakmanshowthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com
[inaudible].